hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
it's the 22nd of July and you're
watching games but nice head of Xbox
Phil Spencer has confirmed that gears of
war Ultimate Edition which remasters the
original gears game will arrive on Xbox
one before it comes to PC in response to
fan questions on Twitter Spencer replied
gears on Windows 10 is later than the
xbox one version we don't have a release
date yet for the pc version but the xbox
one version will arrive on august 25 you
can pick it up for 40 of your
hard-earned dollars microsoft has also
said that a three hundred and fifty
dollar xbox one bundle will arrive on
that same date which will include a copy
of the game according to Microsoft chief
financial officer Amy hood the Xbox one
is gaining momentum in sales thanks to
backwards compatibility and its
exclusive during the latest earnings
presentation who had spoke favorably
about the xboxes recent strong
performance saying this progress as well
as the excitement we generated at e3
with Xbox exclusive gaming content and
backwards compatibility demonstrates the
building momentum that exists within the
Xbox ecosystem the ps4 was the top
selling console in the u.s. last month
but the xbox one outsold the ps4 during
the week of e3 everybody gets a win so
let's move on from this hazardous
console war topic speaking of backwards
compatibility there is a new most
requested game topping the charts of
what gamers most want to see brought to
Xbox one there's a poll on the Xbox
feedback site where users can vote for
the games they most want to see get
backwards compatibility for several
weeks the top spot was held by red dead
redemption but now call of duty black
ops 2 has taken its place this shouldn't
come as a huge surprise since there are
six call of duty games in the top 12
most requested games for backwards
compatibility you can obviously vote on
Microsoft's poll for yourself but here's
a roundup of the games people most want
to see come to Xbox one
in the third spot is Skyrim followed by
modern warfare 2 halo reach call of duty
black ops the first Gears of War 3
fallout 3 2 more modern warfare games
and then mass effect 3 Microsoft are
using the pole as the way to gauge
interest but they haven't said this
necessarily means every game on the list
will get xbox one backwards
compatibility let me know down in the
comments which game tops your list to
bring to Xbox one you can head to games
but we've got stories on Dead Island
definitive edition and the latest ps4
stability update those everything I have
for you today let me know what mattered
to you when I'll catch you again
tomorrow